you
I
cephas class of 2009 depart columbia for
new lives scattered across the globe
sepa itself is beginning a new era in
its history in 2015 we will move to a
spectacular new building just five
blocks from where we are now a building
with plenty of elevators and a real
cafeteria in the meantime the school
will join the ranks of Columbia's great
and independently self-governing
professional schools on July first of
this year implement a new curriculum in
the fall and continue its new role as a
key player in the accelerating
globalization of columbia university
itself sefa will also need to raise
enormous sums of money to make this
possible no graduate of the school no
matter how far away will ever again be
safe from the outstretched hands and
relentless email reminders of Cephas
fundraising department the class of two
thousand nine is already off to a great
start with a wonderful class class gift
for Cephas ever needy fellowship fund
before introducing our commencement
speaker I would like to acknowledge the
presence of a large number of Cephas
distinguished faculty time is too short
to mention all of the path-breaking
books scholarly articles case studies
and reports of all kinds that they
produced just during the past year alone
nor to list their courses and read from
their amazing course evaluations
submitted by their students but i will
ask them to stand for just a moment so
we can recognize their contributions to
the success and a future success of the
class of two thousand
Harry Truman once said if you need a
friend in Washington get a dog it is
rare in public life as many here already
know to enter the rough-and-tumble world
at the intersection of politics and
international affairs and emerge with
more friends and admirers than you start
with our commencement speaker today has
somehow managed to do that Brent
Scowcroft was born in Ogden Utah in 1925
he was still a cadet at West Point when
World War two ended he graduated in 1947
and joined the Army Air Corps which
shortly formed the nucleus of the new
United States Air Force his flying
career ended when engine trouble over
New Hampshire forced him to crash-land
his crippled plane and a forest clearing
he survived a broken back and other
injuries resuming his career as an
instructor first at West Point and later
after a posting in Yugoslavia and other
adventures at the new US Air Force
Academy he was such a talented teacher
that the Air Force decided to send him
to Columbia University to get proper
credentials he received his MA in 1953
and the PhD in 1967 in political science
specializing in international relations
both his MA thesis on the struggle for
Trieste between Italy yo slavia and
their respective friends and enemies and
his doctoral dissertation entitled
Congress and foreign policy and
examination of congressional attitudes
toward the foreign aid programs to Spain
in Yugoslavia two major controversies in
the early of the early Cold War both of
these documents can be found in butler
library and read with profit with a PhD
from Columbia Brent Scowcroft could have
opted for the exciting career of a
college professor rising to tenure
and possibly even to be a Dean
unaccountably he had other things in
mind since 1997 however he has served on
the CEPA advisory board where he has
provided indispensable advice and
encouragement to more than one Dean in
2005 he received cephas Global
Leadership Award to add to a long list
of medals and awards he has earned in a
long and distinguished career Brent
Scowcroft is best known of course for
his tireless and effective public
service heroes in the Air Force ranks
during 25 years of service to the rank
of lieutenant-general he served twice as
US national security advisor first to
President Gerald Ford from 1974 to 1977
and again to President George HW Bush
from 1980 92 93 he played a crucial role
in guiding u.s. foreign policy during
the era that saw the collapse of the
Soviet Union and the end of the Cold War
the book the book he wrote with the
first president Bush about these years
has become a classic for three decades
every US president in need of a misson
honest nonpartisan advice on matters of
national security and international
strategy has called upon Brent Scowcroft
though some have listened more than
others on August fifteenth 2002 six
months before the fateful US invasion of
Iraq Brent Scowcroft publish a white
published a widely cited up ad in The
Wall Street Journal entitled don't
attack Saddam it would undermine our
anti-terror efforts in it he wrote these
words the United States could certainly
defeat the Iraqi military and destroy
Sodom regime but it would not be a
cakewalk on the contrary it would
undoubtedly it undoubtedly would be very
expensive with serious consequences for
the US and global economy and could as
well be bloody it is a great pleasure to
present to you a man whose clear head
the personal integrity and dedication to
public service has earned him the
friendship and respect of so many world
leaders including and he will tell you
in an unguarded moment if you ask some
of the most cantankerous people on the
planet General Scott
games coatsworth distinguished faculty
distinguished guests graduates of the
class of 2009 it's a great pleasure and
a special honor for me to be with you
today Dean cotesworth that very long and
very generous introduction almost makes
me anxious to hear what I have to say
well I did not have the privilege of
attending secret I was at Columbia
during cephas formative years and my
daughter is AC / graduated so I have a
special feeling of kinship to all of you
out there I want to tell all of you who
are graduating that I've SAT there often
enough that I know exactly what you're
thinking at this moment that I am the
only thing standing between you your
diploma and the rest of your lives I
promise to be mercifully brief but not
so brief as Winston Churchill when he
addressed a class of British prep school
students he got up said never never
never give up and sat back down I fully
subscribed to his theme but will not be
quite so succinct you are very lucky I
expect you know that but by now maybe
taking it somewhat for granted you have
been pursuing your studies that one of
the most outstanding institutions of its
kind in the world not to duplicate what
Dean cotesworth said but cheaper was
founded in the aftermath of World War
two with the goal of perfect preparing
professionals to do hands-on work in the
world's new
national and multinational institutions
the scope of this mission has inevitably
expanded over the more than 60 years of
its history as the environment has
changed its sixteen thousand alumni now
form a global community of professionals
dedicated to serving the public in the
private sector as well as government
agencies and not-for-profit
organizations they're wrecking in over a
hundred and fifty countries to improve
social services advocate for Human
Rights strengthen markets improve help
eliminate poverty protect the
environment and secure peace and see
itself has become as international as
its students through partnerships with a
growing number of policy schools in
global cities such as London Paris
Berlin Singapore Beijing Mexico City and
Sao Paulo and of course you have had the
bonus benefit of pursuing your studies
in New York City the international
center of finance home of the United
Nations and many corporations and
not-for-profit organizations you are now
actively entering a world a world
undergoing a historical discontinuity
though you may not perceive it as such
it will certainly be so recorded in
history books of the future there are
two aspects of this discontinuity which
I'd like to discuss the first is the end
of the Cold War for you all that's
ancient history but it is yesterday in
historical terms the cold where wasn't a
period of intense bypoll rivalry taking
place under the omnipresent threat of a
nuclear Cataclysm should either side
make a serious miscalculate
the security focus on that period was
entirely on a single target a single
threat which dominated almost every
aspect of our lives and shaped most of
our security related institutions
suddenly in the blink of an eye
historically speaking that world
disappeared it was replaced by a world
which were virtually the polar opposite
of the Cold War gone was a single enemy
and the apocalyptic threat of nuclear
war in his place emerged a world from
under the nuclear cloud but facing a
myriad of small but complicated and
sometimes unfamiliar with security
issues I liken the change to looking
through opposite ends of a toss hope the
other aspect of this historical
discontinuity the monster merged much
more gradually and many of its earlier
manifestations were masked by the Cold
War this aspect I think could both
usefully described as globalization
which is an overworked word but
globalization not in the sense of a
policy but as a powerful and pervasive
world force in a way this march of
globalization in which we're undergoing
constitutes an assault on the nation
safe system set up in 1648 by the Treaty
of Westphalia a system which reached its
zenith in the nineteenth and twentieth
centuries this system of nation-states
itself had replaced the funeral
political order of the Middle Ages but
now political borders are eroding
states can no longer provide for their
citizens in the manner to which they
historically have been a customer issues
such as health climate capital flows
information technology and many others
define national borders and require
international cooperation to make
progress some have a different impact
information technology for example is
resulting in the politicization of the
world's people for most of history the
average person knew what was happening
his own village and maybe next door but
little more and didn't much care the
great enterprises of empire and so on
washed over these people without so much
as the thought at present however
virtually everyone is within earshot of
a radio I shot of a television and they
know what is going on in the world and
they're energized by it whether it's
envy hatred admiration whatever and much
of the volatility of this world can be
ascribed to the politicization of its
members while all these forces are
presenting new challenges to the
nation-state they are also encouraging
the atomization of political enemies
into ever smaller and more homogeneous
groups Yugoslavia is a good example set
up basically under the urging of the
united states after world war one it was
a very small nation it is now seven many
nations these collaborating many states
of which yugoslavia is just an example
or even less able
than the more traditional states to cope
with the new forces which are pouring
across their borders so you're
graduating into a world sharply
different from that of your parents the
world of the Cold War and one which
characterized as a uneasy coexistence at
present between the westphalian nation
state system and a globalizing world in
addition we are trying to cope with this
complex world with habits of thinking
and especially with institutions
designed for the very different world of
the Cold War this is apparent everywhere
around us just a few examples the
financial crisis revealed a single
economic world any event which took
place anywhere in this economic world
immediately cascaded around the world
but there is no corresponding political
structure to deal with this single
economic structure and as we have seen
there is a rush now in dealing with this
toward the old nation-state beggar their
neighbor the legislation to deal with
the crisis in the United States had a by
American clause in it eerily reminiscent
of the Holly smooth tariff of 1932 what
are the international organizations to
deal with this kind of crisis the
Bretton Woods organizations wonderful
set of institutions put together in 1944
which is a world long path there are
other examples
the US intelligence committee was
organized at the outset of the Cold War
to deal with this single enemy the
Soviet Union we knew a lot about it we
studied it carefully suddenly that's
gone and in place of this single threat
there are hundreds of threats sometimes
we can't even figure out whether their
threats or not and that's part of the
reason for the turmoil and the
intelligence community NATO a wonderful
military alliance actually knows how to
fight together but for what the purpose
for which NATO was founded is
non-existent now are we able to take
that wonderful military organization and
apply it to the problems of a world very
different from that which it was
designed for and lastly the United
Nations constructed 1945 with 51 members
and those members were states of
long-standing similar in traditions
history some democratic some
authoritarian and so on now the United
Nations is a hundred and ninety-two
members and those new States most of
them were not even in existence in 1945
or were satellites were colonies of the
50-run original members with thoughts of
mind about how the world ought to be
organized that are very different from
the original 50 51 and the UN carries
within it the seeds of this contest
article 2 of the UN says nothing in this
Charter shall give the right for this
organization to interfere in matters
essentially within the domestic
jurisdiction of its state of its members
that is the westphalian system on the
other hand
the United Nations has passed twice
passed resolutions called the
responsibility to protect which says if
a state does not or cannot protect major
elements of its population it is the
duty of the United Nations to interfere
those two are in direct conflict with
each other this is the world that you
all are inheriting one more complicated
than your ancestors for ages past and
moving at a pace your ancestors could
never even have imagined and I said at
the outset you could not be better
prepared for the adventure on which
you're embarking you're now standing on
the threshold of one of life's major
transitions society has been given to
you thus far in your lives that will
soon end if not now after some more
studies we all the things we cherish
most to the sacrifices of those who have
gone before us your parents and your
grandparents One World War two and the
Cold War and it is their legacy you're
enjoying now is about to be your turn to
give reflect for a moment on true
essentials what for example would you
like your epitaph to say I turn again to
Winston Churchill who said you make a
living by what you earn you make a life
by what you give I am confident that you
would embrace those powerful words and
would thoughtfully consider public
service for two reasons
first there's something enormously
fulfilling about being engaged in
something larger than yourself it
imparts a satisfying sense of purpose
which in my experience is not attained
in any other way and beyond that there
is a desperate need in this country and
for others of you from abroad in your
own country for people to man the
government structures i well know it is
getting more and more difficult at least
in this country to be a public servant
we've driven many of our best people
away your private life is made public
your finances are bared your integrity
is questioned but I ask you to consider
public service not because it's easy but
because it's hard it's rewarding and oh
so necessary how well the wonderful
things this nation stands for will be
preserved and projected will depend on
the quality of the people whose hands
are on the helm of state how man can
cope with the problems that I have
described in others over the next 50
years those are your years will depend
inordinately on the behavior of the
United States only the US can mobilize
the international community to the tax
tasks which need to be accomplished if
we do not lead little can be done it may
not always be that way but for most of
your lies that will simply be effect but
public service does not necessarily have
to mean joining the government in
Washington or 18 or Berlin or anywhere
else non-governmental organizations
volunteerism school boards local elected
office all of these are necessary to
preserve
our wonderful heritage to enrich it and
pass it on one final word set your
sights high it does no harm except to
your ego to fail now Nana hockey star
Wayne Gretzky once said you miss one
hundred percent of the shots you don't
take so never be afraid to take your
best shot thank you good luck and God
bless you
you
now I am pleased to introduce director
Steven Cohen who will present the 58
candidates for the degree of Master of
Public Administration in environmental
science and policy
Bert first okay well before i do that i
guess i'm going to read joseph semanek
who is the SI possa mpa co-president
and now it's my privilege to call to the
platform the outstanding class of two
thousand nine of the NPA in
environmental science and policy
starting with Dana Adeline
Kira appleby maha abu bakar bahoon down
adelia Danya cuevas Fletcher the going
Ryan black
Cheban burns
Stephen Caputo jr. Natalie Chalmers
Nathan Chen
Louisa Chan
William Riley covin jr. Gabe Cole's Dana
coil Betty Crimmins
Molly the south
Aaron Duggan Marcy Fiedler Maria 30
Povich the manual for the mall Diane boy
Miriam gabay
grant goodridge
jennifer holler
zeeshan ha Russia
Judith Harwood Alexander Hoffman
elise huddle
emmanuelle on bleh
kenneth kaseman
Joseph cats
kara kerckhoff
Carolyn Langford
Erica the young
James Marshall
Rochelle Mehcad knee Jessica McHugh
Aaron McKinnon Monica Miller
Vanessa Morris
Lisa niggy no sister the bow
calder or
Danielle rabbit Jana Robbins
Julie roulette
Carlos rhymer
80 Anna Hazare oh
Susie shuford
thomas citizen
Emily small
Leah Stokes
le tange
Daniel title Val
alexandra Varga
Christina arianny wartenberg and last
but not least brett williams
it is my pleasure to present the
graduates of the EMP a class of 2009
starting with Catalina Alvarez Ryan aims
Carlos bacca Kimberly Annette Philippe
Vontae raluca kadar Anthony Cerrone
Kim line chain Matthew chillin Helen
Chung
willer cipriani Maria common areas Nancy
Conde boubacar dia Bertrand Yuri Mariela
clambering Jacqueline Franco Dayven
friedenberg carry Gallagher
Stephanie yellow even Garcia John
Gardner
lara green Specter
Joleon handler allow a son
mark hangs William Jimenez Scott car
Colin Kelly hilton klinkenberg
Richard letran 0
Valerie Leon hamara levy more Ross level
yongnuo Vivian Martinez Rivera Hoshi
bizarre Richard McFarland hermes manner
for same montano Susan Marie Tiffany
novinger Cheryl nurse Patrick O'Connell
marwa othman Miriam Ahmed Sri Lauren
para Jacqueline Pineda a la Rock off
Filipa ciao
Mark Thomas
Angela side heavy woodfield and whopping
John congratulations
you
I am delighted to welcome and introduce
web M graduates 2009 pass it Mesut
abbasi Zeno Ronald abhinaya carlos
alvarado esslyn artists ever do nothing
audi
mmmm
Alexander Russia a LAN party Nick
then I 1j wattana jcn Chang
I'll few chain
runner Jim got better
sharing Dana fabuleux the Santos
can put Mercia crud Nicki
Turk Eric Masato Yoshii I damn it for
the notebook
taco eat katarina Casper chick hi Kimmy
hello kwiat a
Jing d Daniel the Quarren sorry miss
tsuzuku Yama Muhammad SWAT right foot
salmon salmon
shahi shake
mihir kumar sinha sooo fat Olga rusev
are searching young
yosuke yes we hit Yoshida you want you
I'm present to you the class of 2009 all
exceptional nationals now prepared to
venture out into the world to fight for
Human improve social services strengthen
mark protect the environment and help
secure peace I to start with our first
graduate please Alex Ashley
amina Oh Dalle
Daniel Alvarez
I mad
Nicola bo chay
Herman Van Lulu
Russia batma guy
Clarice Fleischer brown
Bobo stafa
kelly campbell
sickness katawa heaven chamblee
Oh Chang
seeming chain
sorry Chaudhary Valerie together
touch Odin pellet Christina Korea
maria de Castella Maria
a main ideas
Carlos Carlos Diaz
Alicia Alicia dick machi draws it my
soul Espinoza no Amelia field Marco free
osawa yoshiki
these Garcia Pharaoh
listing true Christopher guess
calcium or who may june july buck Yuki
he shot me d Fame who tirana Hasani
Michael Hines
lino abrar oh please
Donald Joe
troi oi cool um
simrad cracking up
medina chasm food waiver
Elizabeth kini
mouhamed from
unas clapper
Paul ho
Crystal's call them in our case
ok Tamil la salle ski Camilla letreros
Gonzalez
Thank You Leslie
Jordan love
coolio merciful pilas Charles martorana
amina masood Sasha McDowell Len miles
Cully biscuit Natasha mystery Carlos
moro Moscow roco morrow Quinn oh nice
one pablo morales takuya murata
marina Negroponte Gregory Nichols
Tobias Neiman's maria laura newest
Santoshi ogawa kogato Undead Julia or
toss Rios Alfonso alsa yo ho Jung ho
park
Mia Polly she
royal Romani Lucilla Gabriella race
aundrea Freeman li mo Rodriguez
Rodriguez you go Rodriguez Nikola rafael
rodriguez lil Torres Stacy merwin Paulo
Rona's szabados Rebecca rouse
Emma sense of wonder risco
sir Wow gudren siga Don detour
the equal of Simpsons comm Sarah panic
Lee he squares sala Jung Joo son
sarita subramanian Christopher furlough
sir thomaa no Leo's co gio Triana same
Wilhemina same knee high sing yoshiharu
umihara Juliet he draw keyboard bellagio
ish
so same boat Melissa weights Robbie Oh
lekar Catlin Welsh
coughing white chocolate open from
andreea Woodley
possum out Yousef
salad Giada ye yang
you
and now for the m.i.a degree recipient
Bernardo the Basel Lopez
tsubasa macau a brave Kirsten halgren
Perez Ahmad
cydia ahmad
yoo jung on Matthew aho be I shangela
syed on fire Rosie Rosina Ali Salim all
jewelry
Lydia Talon
Mark Allen
Anna almonds
oh my Island are we
Massimo Albion
Joshua amata
I Dahlia Amaya Xena our fast
Assad sham shock
Abu Oscar
Catherine offense Athens CD
maria oven janata tsuki owashi
mayor or tani Anna ah spora hockey
Barack
shubha Bala
Shaylee Barnes
eliza base
Caroline Baxter Emily Bell marry Ben
Ashley Benner khaya Benson
diadora berkova
Lisa Bell Sean blaschke
Eleanor bloom strim Lawrence bode
Kirsten vokoun come Natalie bond job
Christina Regina bono on kareena for
debate
Caroline Poulos John Boyd Jacqueline
brown
eugenia eugenia book spoon marcin booze
Ansky Eva Fernandez Christian cardona
Mariano Castillo John mincha Coleman
Chamberlain Rana chan
Ryan Chang
fisa show
vodkas children Liang Chen Sylvester
Chen after Chen Tatiana shuka wrinkle
yoo jung Evelyn Cho Alfred ciao Donna to
Anna Chung
Christian Cleveland
microcline
mervat coco lee delenn Cohen Jane Cowan
Benjamin Cole Murray sarah roemer
Christina Connor sorriso
Joshua cook
Oliver corbeille
Roxanna come I show
Catherine critchell
nicon Coleman Jessica Daniels
DARPA does Gupta Luke Davenport Patrick
diba Frederico do gado ography I'm sorry
oh god did my way
mirai dandy
Christopher the Russian gianpaolo de
martino
Kristen Dobson
Kourtney dog cart
evanna Dario Salla future
Michelle means Caroline a bamboo
Isabella etcheverry
kc early
elona aliza indra ericsson mariana
Escobar three
Terrence favors mario fernandez Nancy
Ferrante Chrissy ferrara Quran feel it
MF it's joe cabling Fitzpatrick
Christopher flavel
matthew plan
Nicole foster Elena fortunato's Mikiko
Pujara fujita Matthew poco
Emily Gann Anjali guard
soshim kafani
James giganti Olivia Himeno steward go
then
John mica colston
Emily GU Yong Amy grace
Daniel Green
Molly rodin Amanda good three
thiago teamer honest
valentina Bernie
Carlos Gutierrez Manzo Baeza high-low
Lin Xiao Han Allison hair Helen Harris
Godfrey Hardman ma'am Hashimi mohamed
osman nafisa us some
Megan hazel Marcy Hirsch well oh yes
Daniel Salazar
kayoko eerie Oprah
Benjamin homes Lisa hope Howard poplin
Jonathan house
brian hoyer
Rebecca Hughes Jonathan Helen
corsa hunt
media hussaini
rehab Hussein
sungha jung wing
vestnik he see me
now for me Ek Tha me class jacobson
gazelle Chopin toss
Elizabeth Jennings jenny jen
Amelia Johnson Joffrey Jones San yuk
shung
Claudia univac Hillary kbecque Stephanie
com
christopher calming /
yatta grande
resume kapoor
Chewie dr. cool
to me Carole cord flora Keating Claire
kels khaldoun Khalil divya khosla
takahiro kadu who your chem
John Kim
sour Kim
son take em
paola can Blanco Benjamin cursor Allen
Anita kirpalani Ahmad p IE
Lucy curls so rpn coach aria
I Yoko Cody Julia Cutler naira chillage
lie sir robert chris lambert
Teresa lang toy mangala
Kristen Lena
s Leo Larson
Katherine wall or John Matthew
leatherman Selena lee daniel we warmly
mequon Lee Sandrine Legrand Scott leo
Michael Leonard Robert T Leonard them
Joseph Len
chang chong Johnny Chang Liu
yang Ling Lou Alvaro London know
michael kors thought
yeah cold see last one Jenna's nor
humming dah makan makan
Scott McKenzie Ruth mcquitty mark
Malaika
Nicholas Marin
Berta marchiori
Clowe Martin heed all go Benjamin Marx
Susanna may sir
I die me so canova
nichole moore yellow
Kevin McCaffrey David McCormack
kemberly McKenna's I leave out McGee
yaakov us michiels Samantha Manassas
hi Tina merci Marie mental uchi villani
masti ki Dahlia more shot
Jesse Morton
Travis Moser yoki mo-chica
shannon mullins
hiromi here are commie
ana carolina Murphy
young any na shoe
natalia negri malwan nine
sawa magagawa Marcel major bond
so via nesterov
Kevin in
now nishiki kawa Hana Ludo
Elizabeth Nunez
yummy she a two men Oh guro
reiko Oh Kimura William aulander Gabriel
Olivia person Oliver
Peter or
tanya de zumba Edward Todd Owens I Kiko
pace valaria pana you toba
shayla for week
Jean Jean park Beulah's pootie Conda
peter savio pavlova Jessica Pierce Joyce
kisser ello savas Politis Miguel Hosanna
sewage prasanna kumar
michael prosser
Ilana pokova Stephen quadri bra kina
kashi raza
Amanda Reed
Virginia row sandy
young read I like Ritter
Paolo rolla Don Julian Rallo
he bra Rosalie's
Andrew Rothman
Audrey broham Regina boss teesta
Roberto solace ahmad muhammad saleem
patty Otto salgo us funny de espana
samper Crisco Sandra Sandoval jessenia
Santana and ce sera me to Russia
Sato
you Ichiro Sato monkey Salman
Joshua Edward Saxon
Rebecca sheer Kenneth schaeffler
Sarah shown heart
Bonnie Schulman
t Tiana sears
Nadia saving BB sha
roshan Shah Danielle shema LaVon sure
shot a liat she treat women short Oh
Julia aksama Julia and Sikorsky
Jennifer Sylvie
Sarah Simone Oh Denise singly linear
small neta so Bonnie
Eugene sokoloff
Rachel sorry
Oh Myra Soriano
Stephen stolte
Meredith Strickler
haeseong soup Claire Sullivan
named ivy son went I son
couch sue on new coal Morton spend store
jameelah Adam Sykes
sir tableau e-tech Maui Jennifer taki
Gowan
perito taki murah
hello Benjamin Tom Elena tancy Taniya
Denver pollen chicken akanksha the core
Alexander song Brandon Thompson
Clea 2n
johann tingle start amelie tower Whitney
Trumbull America 10-4 Rostova
the Goo Goo come Mia oh oops uno Mia
Omar Valdez
Joan van Fossen hobie Victor Vasquez
Alvarez Delphine here Heidi
you
the address official
graduate it is a great honor for me to
be here to say a few words as semi a
pressing of the class of two thousand
nine
today is the very when we celebrate what
we have achieved but before I go on I
want to reinforce the idea that good
manners a sign of good upbringing and I
now encourage my classmates my dear
classmates to stand up and stand up in
front of your families come on my dear
taught me to stand up in front of your
families and thank them for their
support for their time for their
dedication to you your success is their
success
and I now beg your pardon to do exactly
the same to mine own english-speaking
plans for a fraction of a second gracias
Padre gracias madre por darme el
oportunidad estar aqui in preparing this
speech I thought about how clear it is
to me that we owe our family so much but
then I kept thinking how much of our own
life is built on the labors of fathers
how much we owe to so many people whose
names we don't even know of whose
existence we were not even aware but
don't take my word for it Warren Buffett
the American investor businessman the
philanthropist whose estimated net worth
is approximately thirty seven billion
dollars once acknowledged that rather
than his personal strength society is
responsible for much of his wealth he
said and I'm quoting him now if you
stick me down in the middle of
Bangladesh or Peru you will find out how
much this talent is going to produce in
the wrong kind of soil I will also share
with you the similar point of view of
ever Simon and Nobel laureate economies
who estimated the ninety percent of our
individual income is diving related to
the previous world and the good
governance of our countries of course
these are characteristics for which we
cannot take credit our work is important
but clearly so are the circumstances the
tsironis had we been born 100 years ago
or maybe some thousand kilometres south
west or east were our lives would have
been utterly different and we probably
would not have had the opportunities
each of us has enjoyed and I think this
ideas are especially important to note
on a day like today I believe nothing is
more urgent normal important for me
today than to tell you how lucky we are
how privileged we should feel but also
how this will create
some moral responsibility to those who
were not as fortunate to whom much is
given much is expected and I could of
course it's been a long time debating
what is the best way to carry out these
moral responsibility but I don't think
that's necessary I am an optimist and I
know my classmates and I and I have full
faith that the CEPA class of two
thousand nine will fulfill this sense of
duty thank you
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen Dean
Coatsworth 16 faculty parents friends
significant others and those of you were
casually dating Oh on behalf of the
class of 2009 we are overjoyed to have
you here to share the special moment
with all of us your words of
encouragement your support and the loans
you co-signed have helped make this day
possible so how do we begin to express
what sepa has meant to all of us we've
gained far more than our rigorous
academic curriculum would suggest we've
entered this this experience uncertain
of how it would transform our lives you
see the hidden gem of cifra is difficult
to articulate what sets us apart from
other policy and international affairs
programs is our community a super
student learns very early on that the
success of each of us is inextricably
intertwined the constant reminder that
this lesson compels us to support each
other when we struggle and hold each
other accountable when we're not doing
enough so as we gather here this
afternoon united in our diversity and
unsure about what lies ahead I encourage
you I encourage each of us to never
forget the things we know for sure we
know by surviving our first year and the
countless number of group projects that
we are prepared to face any challenge
and have mastered the art of conflict
resolution we know that no matter where
we are in the world John Conway boy will
continue to send us mass text messages
to let us know where the free food and
drinks are
we know that in another minute this 4
minute speech will start to feel a lot
more like 15 so keeping that in mind
I've decided to cut the obligatory
elevator joke that we tend to hear at
these super functions we know that
timing and strategic planning matter
which comes in handy when you're trying
to board the elevators doing during our
peak times that was a bad joke but just
go ahead and laugh we know that the
economy will recover and we will find
jobs I have I have a little bit of proof
and just bear with me this might not
make that much sense right away but a
few students and I have started an
independent research project and we saw
a correlation between the strengthening
economy and the career of Britney Spears
all right it sounds weird sounds weird
but during the days a little back when
Britney had our meltdown gas prices
skyrocketed unemployment rose I got
divorced and stocks plummeted so let's
fast forward to today and since the
release of her new come back CD the
freefall of stocks of slow gas prices
are back to a reasonable a reasonable
level and my new partner makes much more
money than my ex so it's working out yep
so as we as we exit this chapter in our
lives we must do all that we can to
honor and preserve the legacy of this
journey we owe a great debt to sepa for
all it has given us the enthusiasm you
felt about this experience and in this
moment must be carrying with you forever
to quote a famous commencement address
the memories the memories we've shared
will not go away simply because we do so
even if the future does not always meet
our expectations or the fates are cruel
to us at times no one can take the sefa
experience from me from me from you from
any of us thank you very much
good afternoon as we now look forward to
the next step in our lives of
professional careers real lives beyond
the window was classrooms of the fourth
floor and lehman library as we seek
meaningful employment in the most
challenging job market in recent history
we shall always remind ourselves then
every crisis there's always opportunity
John F Kennedy famously said the Chinese
character for crisis has two parts one
represents danger the other represents
opportunity the Chinese were surprised
to hear this as no such character exists
but we can all understand and appreciate
the sentiment and perhaps as soon to be
super graduates we can take heart that
despite these challenges the same skills
intellect and good fortune that allowed
us to matriculate into Columbia
University nearly two years ago will
most likely continue to serve us well in
the future and even if I'm wrong I hear
the business school in Los will have
great programs but in all seriousness to
anyone who has had the privilege to
spend a few hours roaming the halls of
the international affairs building or
time to send a class you can't help but
appreciate the incredible diversity of
our class see if the students are truly
an international mosaic we are from as
far away as he says every from Columbia
well heart from Kazakhstan Russia from
India and we are as close to home as
Sara Dutcher from Queens Donald foo
Chicago Rebecca from Southern California
and Jordan from Montana our professional
backgrounds are as varied as the
countries we call home while some of us
did work for the Peace Corps others
bring a range of experience from foreign
governments the military and the private
sector and although we are now at the
end of our two-year academic experience
let me underscore that the personal
relationships that we developed over
this two-year experience or what we will
take away from ciba long after
graduation day these are the
relationships that will sustain us a
career in any field and as many of us go
on to run down profits work in
government pursue careers in banking and
consulting we are never more than a
phone call text or email away from one
another hopefully the collection of
friends and colleagues that we leave
with today will not only continue to
make us laugh but continue to challenge
the way we think about ourselves and the
world having said that please continue
to reach out to one another in the years
to come so the superclass of 2009 thank
you and God speed
in the short time
I have been privileged to serve as dean
of this great school nothing has
impressed me more than the intelligence
idealism maturity and fearlessness of
cpas extraordinary students I
congratulate all of you on your success
at sepa and wish every one of you a life
made more rewarding and complete by the
joy joy of struggling for a better world
this concludes the graduation ceremony
for the super class of 2009 my thanks to
one and all and congratulations to the
graduating